well welcome everyone thank you for
adjusting and being here this morning
you know it's been an emotionally
charged couple of weeks as all of you
know and I've been considering what my
options are and throughout this whole
process there have been two polarizing
audiences at one end of the spectrum
we've had Patriot fans throughout the
country who have been so supportive and
really inspirational to us and believing
in US but I'm also mindful at the other
end of the spectrum there are fans that
you feel just the opposite and what I've
learned is the ongoing rhetoric
continues to galvanize both camps and I
don't see that changing and they will
never agree but the one thing that we
all can agree upon is the entire process
has taken way too long and I don't think
anyone can believe that after four
months of the AFC Championship game we
are still talking about air pressure in
the PSI in footballs so I think I made
it clear when the report came out that I
didn't think it was fear there was no
hard evidence and everything was
circumstantial and at the same time when
the discipline came out I felt it was
way over the top as it was unreasonable
and unprecedented in my opinion so I
have two options I can try to end it or
extend it and I have given a lot of
thought to both options the first thing
that came to mind is
21 years ago I had the privilege of
going to a meeting similar to what we
had here in Orlando and being welcomed
in an NFL owners meeting so here's a fan
and a former season ticket holder in
living a dream and being welcomed in
that room and I got goosebumps that day
and I've out at that time that I would
do everything I could do to make the New
England Patriots an elite team and
hopefully respected throughout the
country and at the same time do whatever
I could do to try to help the NFL become
the most popular sport in America you
know what I've learned over the last two
decades is at the heart of solon of the
strength of the NFL that is a
partnership of 32 teams and what's been
come very clear over those two decades
that at no time should the agenda of one
team outweigh the collective good of the
full 32 so I have a way of looking at
problems that are very strong in my mind
and before I make a final decision I
measure nine times and I cut once and I
think maybe if I had made the decision
last week it would be different that it
is today but believing in the strength
of the partnership and the 32 teams we
we have concentrated the power of
adjudication of problems in the office
of the commissioner and although I might
disagree with what is decided I do have
respect for the commissioner and believe
that he's doing what he perceives to be
in the best in
rest of the full 32 so in that spirit I
don't want to continue the rhetoric
that's gone on for the last four months
I'm going to accept reluctantly what he
has given to us and not continue this
dialogue and rhetoric and we won't
appeal now I know that a lot of Patriot
fans are going to be disappointed in
that decision but I hope they trust my
judgment and know that I really feel at
this point in time that taking this off
the agenda this is the best thing for
the New England Patriots our fans and
the NFL and I hope you all can respect
that you know I would normally take
questions but my desire is truly not
continue the rhetoric and so I'm going
to leave this discussion exactly here
thank you very much